[Música]
imagínense todos estuvieron en la cabina
de un avión un avión clásico en donde
nos subimos y hay que empujar un poco a
la gente para acomodarse poder meter la
maleta
finalmente nos podemos sentar y en este
avión empiezan a escucharse en el
altoparlante lo típico el capitán del
avión es diciendo las indicaciones
clásicas a dónde vamos a llegar
en la velocidad que va a adquirir el
avión durante el vuelo el horario que
vamos a llegar el horario destino
y dentro de todas las cosas que dicen
uno no está tomando mucho la atención
pero de repente interrumpe y hacia el
final dice quisiera decirles y
agradecerles porque este es mi primer
vuelo real
entonces les pregunto a ustedes que
generan en ustedes una sensación de
susto algunos se bajarían del avión por
ejemplo yo me imagino que los pilotos
deben debutar al desierto es poco
probable que uno siempre huele no no lo
hace volando entonces probablemente el
capitán no tendría que decirlo pero
pasa
qué ocurre entre nosotros porque
nosotros confiamos en el sistema
porque confiamos en este sistema en
donde básicamente no creemos que vaya a
pasar algo malo cierto probablemente en
nuestro inconsciente creemos que la
aviación es muy segura existe algún dato
sobre
en un accidente es de 3 personas en 10
d
el problema es bajo básicamente estamos
hablando de que lo han minimizado al
mínimo es prácticamente muy seguro y es
muy comparable y que te caiga un rayo y
hay uno se muere entonces que ha hecho
la aviación como ha logrado disminuir el
error humano
en dos pilotos en tren y en el
entrenamiento lo que estábamos viendo
acá es que están volando un boeing 787
volador el simulador es espectacular y
pueden hacer todo tipo de condiciones
condiciones como por ejemplo que se
apaguen todos los motores condiciones
que son pesadillas para un piloto
condiciones como todo tipo climático que
aparezca un tornado o todo lo que
ustedes se imaginan entonces lo que han
podido mostrar es que estando en este
simulador de vuelo y después transfieren
las habilis al escenario real
espectáculo o sea tenemos una
transferencia de entrenamiento al avión
real que ocurre en otras áreas en otras
áreas como la mía que es la cirugía cómo
es hoy en día una cirugía fíjense lo que
están haciendo estos dos cirujanos es un
procedimiento complejo
haciendo con mucha tecnología pueden ver
que el cirujano con unas pinzas está
pudiendo alterar la anatomía dentro del
cuerpo y con mucha tecnología como
pueden ver miran hacia las pantallas y
no son sólo una pantalla son varias y la
verdad ya no es la típica cirugía con
una incisión grande que uno miraba la
herida y empezó a actuar cada vez más
tenemos este tipo de cirugías y cuál es
el problema es difícil obtener la
técnica para poder hacer este tipo de
cirugías la curva aprendizaje es
prolongada es muy larga la forma
tradicional de aprender esto es que un
residente que es un alumno de cirugía
general pudiese hacer de primer año debe
exponerse a operar esto con un maestro y
cuando está operando con un maestro el
maestro va a ir viendo si es que aprende
y a medida que aprenda le va a ir
cediendo pacientes pero siempre
supervisado para seguridad por por la
seguridad del paciente y finalmente
entonces este alumno
y convertirse en un cirujano y poder
hacer esto solo con este tipo de técnica
y tecnología cuesta mucho hacerlo
entonces nosotros como paciente así como
fuimos pasajeros en el avión que
hablamos antes que sentimos cuando nos
vamos a operar probablemente nos
entregamos también confiamos en el
sistema cuál es el error desde el punto
de vista en el área de la salud es
parecida a la aviación el error según la
organización mundial de la salud es que
puede haber uno dentro de 300 casos no
estamos hablando de que sea una muerte
en 300 sino que un error en el área de
salud en 300 casos esto es muy alto algo
está mal algo tenemos que poder cambiar
si vemos entonces el ejemplo la aviación
la pregunta es si existe algo para
cambiar esto existe por ejemplo este
simulador 787 hay alguna simulación en
la medicina y puntualmente en el ejemplo
que vimos la cirugía de laparoscopia que
es la que vimos este es el simulador que
se ofrece en todo el mundo esto es el
entrenamiento propuesto por las
organizaciones mundiales y es lo que hay
que hacer si se ve es un poco básico me
hubiera gustado esas turbinas
hidráulicas que tenía el 787 pero la
verdad es que al menos es algo es una
buena introducción y estamos moviendo
entonces un plástico de un lado al otro
lado entonces la pregunta que viene a
nuestra cabeza es
podemos pasar de este tipo de
entrenamientos a este tipo de cirugía
y al menos lo que nosotros nos
planteamos en esa época ocho años atrás
es que todo realmente no creíamos que
fuese posible y había que demostrar al
menos es que de estos plásticos uno
podía adquirir las habilidades
necesarias
es un entrenamiento que parece una
introducción al paciente más que fuese
más difícil yo sé la pregunta es es
mejorable lo que nos ofrece el mundo
pero estamos en chile es mejorable
podemos hacer algo si queremos empezar a
programar o a diseñar un programa de
entrenamiento que debe tener queremos
que no sea una introducción a un
paciente queremos que sea mucho más
difícil que un paciente lo que buscamos
entonces es que después de entrenar el
paciente sea fácil para que no hay error
entonces si vemos otro ejemplo más allá
de la aviación la nasa si usted se
imaginan ellos hicieran la introducción
a una misión a marte probablemente
tienen que hacer una simulación que es
mucho más difícil todos los escenarios
posibles para que no fallen y así
entonces eliminan todo el error humano
que pueda haber y todo tipo de errores
que puedan cometer y así no se pone en
riesgo obviamente la tripulación todos
los astronautas etcétera etcétera
entonces con esto en mente cómo podemos
hacer un súper
no tenemos el presupuesto de la nasa
entonces se nos ocurrió que un modelo
muy sencillo que es un intestino que se
puede conseguir en cualquier carnicería
puede generar un ejercicio muy difícil
hacer exactamente lo que hacen en
pacientes hacer la unión de dos
intestinos de forma laparoscópica y esto
hacerlo en el simulador para eso
necesitábamos hacer mediciones y estas
mediciones nos permitirían entender si
el modelo sirve o no teníamos 25
residentes que medir de primer año de
cirugía general
aquí se ven los puntos cada uno de estos
puntos es un residente y lo que llama la
atención entonces es que tenemos una
distribución enormes es bien heterogéneo
al grupo pero les podría resumir en que
tienen una calidad técnica muy baja y
esto es lo normal porque recién se
graduaron de medicina y ahora están
adquiriendo de a poco sus destrezas y
nunca habían hecho nada laparoscópico
entonces llama mucho la atención a estos
puntos ahí separado de todo de todo el
grupo aparece una persona ahí que
pareciera como que es un maestro
nunca entrenado y ya saca un puntaje que
es bastante cercano al máximo al nivel
experto entonces este este punto la
pregunta es
/ no antes como lo hizo no sabemos ahora
el punto que está los puntos que están
alrededor del círculo rojo del círculo
rojo que está mostrando básicamente que
hay muchas personas que tienen el peor
puntaje al iniciar el entrenamiento si
nosotros pudiésemos entonces agarrar a
todo este grupo entrenarlo por sesiones
y pudiéramos entonces corregir sus
errores obtendríamos una curva de
aprendizaje y esto es lo que hicimos
esa es la curva post de entrenamiento y
duró 16 sesiones del entrenamiento
fíjense que todo el grupo mejora al
nivel sobre el nivel experto
espectacular teníamos un programa de
entrenamiento muy bueno y llama mucho la
atención bueno esta persona que era el
talentoso mejora también y estaba muy
contento porque lograba entonces
ejecutar muy bien el ejercicio pero
fíjense dónde queda los que eran los
peores al inicio del entrenamiento
quedan muy bien incluso sobre el nivel
experto
entonces teníamos un super programa un
programa que permitía entrenar alumnos y
dejarlos en un nivel sobre experto si
vemos antes del entrenamiento y ahora lo
comparamos a post entrenamiento vemos
que todos son mejores que el más
talentoso le inició el entrenamiento la
práctica hace que una persona pueda ser
superior técnicamente que alguien
talentoso que simplemente está ahí por
la vida sin entrenar
teníamos un súper programa este programa
entonces convertir a novatos en expertos
y les adelanto pudimos hacer otra
investigación en que demostramos que
estos súper novatos le llamamos están
tan entrenados que los comparamos a
cirujanos generales
un paciente esta vez supervisado por un
experto y los novatos eran muy
superiores a los cirujanos generales sin
simulación
el problema es que los simuladores el
hardware estaba diseñado para hacer
entrenamientos básicos mover un plástico
de un lado el otro lado podrían ser
incluso en blanco y negro entonces
teníamos una opción esperar a que el
mundo nos ofreciera un simulador para
nuestro programa y hacer un simulador y
con eso en mente y haciendo asociaciones
interdisciplinar pudimos construir un
simulador este simulador nos permitía
entonces tener alta definición y poder
hacer en elche un chile que vieron un
ejercicio muy bueno y teníamos entonces
un muy buen programa y el simulador
empezaron a venir los alumnos empezaron
a venir un día miércoles un día viernes
y estando en el laboratorio junto a un
amigo que es veterinario nos empezamos a
preguntar quién les enseña
llamemos a los expertos llamábamos y no
podían venir estaban siempre ocupados
entonces uno dice pero como diseñamos un
tremendo programa y nos van a venir los
expertos a enseñarles y les hago esta
siguiente analogía aquí ven uno de los
juegos más famosos de playstation el
fifa y con el fifa yo tengo amigos que
son expertos en fijos tanto el día 8
horas diarias son una máquina de fifa y
si uno les pide ellos que nos enseñan a
jugar fifa probablemente nos enseñen muy
bien son espectacularmente buenos para
decirte no hace esto aprieta este botón
y en dos segundos uno se empieza a
volver experto en fifa si le pido a
cristiano ronaldo que sale en la foto
quien nos enseña a jugar fifa quizás no
sea tan bueno nos va a enseñar a jugar
bien fútbol pero fifa no sé si tiene el
tiempo para estar jugando y siendo muy
experto si volvemos a la simulación eso
es lo que hicimos nos planteamos si era
posible que nosotros un veterinario y en
esa época médico general
podíamos o no
a la gente que venía tuvimos que
aprender entonces ser retroalimentación
enseñar bien cómo mejorar cómo corregir
el error y entonces con eso nos volvimos
el tercer pilar pudimos entonces tener
un programa muy bueno el simulador y
ahora teníamos docentes nos empezó a ir
muy bien desde el punto vista científico
empezamos a mostrar esta experiencia en
estados unidos y otros lados aquí les
muestro cómo se ve montado un gimnasio
entrenamiento se ven los simuladores la
gente va a entrenar esto fue montado en
el congreso más importante que hay en
eeuu de cirugía laparoscópica y la
verdad que le gustaba mucho la gente de
asia de eeuu decían es espectacular pero
está claro cómo puedo hacer esto y
nosotros nos tratamos de responder estos
tienen que ir a chile
entonces espero como no lo podemos hacer
acá en eeuu es decir nos gustaría pero
pero no es tan fácil como llevamos a los
expertos como llegamos los tres pilares
es muy difícil esto
o no se puede hacer algo así como
podemos llevar todo este sistema al
resto del mundo y ese es un desafío no
no pequeño pero estamos en el siglo 21 y
hay tecnología lo que tratamos de
proponer es una especie de uber de la
cirugía laparoscópica en donde es un
proyecto ambicioso pero se lo pueda
tratar de explicar se llama lab que es
la
va a un alumno x en una parte del mundo
x va a entrenar a un gimnasio se pone a
entrenar y el que debe entrenar lo que
había en un vídeo que se podría haber
descargado después de este vídeo se sube
a una nube y ahora una vez que está en
la nube si lo capta una red docente
entrenada por nosotros así como
entrenamos en fifa podemos entrenar en
cómo evaluar esto y podemos masificar en
la red docente entonces tenemos la
opción de evaluar a alguien que está en
otra parte del mundo y que esta persona
pueda adquirir la mejoría de por ejemplo
corregir todos los errores y llegar a
esa curva aprendizaje que les mostré al
inicio después de que el profesor ve
exactamente dónde está el error lo marca
le manda un vídeo de cómo corregirlo y
un audio
entonces el alumno recibe ahora este
feedback lo pueden mil veces porque le
queda para siempre
de nuevo al gimnasio y puede entrenarse
esto es un sueño la verdad para nosotros
en simulación no se ha sido algo
increíble imagínense poder llegar a luz
de esto el mundo es un sueño que en
chile ya es realidad en chile hemos
logrado gracias la sociedad de cirujanos
de chile simulación no sé y la industria
un esfuerzo colaborativo enorme empezar
a entrenar las regiones armamos gimnasio
en distintas regiones y no tienen que
viajar a santiago entonces con estos los
cirujanos están entrenándose
efectivamente y estamos viendo
resultados que son muy parecidos a los
que obtuvimos antes
cuál es el límite
como cuestionarse entonces las cosas
pueden generar de ideas simples una idea
con 'la con alto potencial como este
potencial puede impactar incluso al
mundo y cuando impactamos al mundo
siempre recordemos que podemos
transformar una persona que pudiese
estar en el colegio pudiese estar en
cualquier etapa de formación de una
etapa en donde puede desempeñarse quizás
técnicamente con poca destreza pero que
sabemos que con práctica podría llegar a
un alto nivel y esta persona en cirugía
al menos va a impactar a muchas otras a
muchos pacientes miles miles miles de
pacientes y todos estos pacientes
finalmente van a tener un algo en común
van a haber sido expuestos a mucho menor
error humano muchas gracias
[Aplausos]